Dubai has almost no oil left.
Less than 1% of its economy runs on it.
So how does a desert city pull in 30 million tourists a year
and host more billionaires than most countries?
It starts with zero income tax.
For individuals and until recently, most businesses too.
That single policy turned Dubai into a magnet
for global wealth.
Add over 30 free trade zones where foreign companies
can own 100% of their business, pay no corporate tax,
and move profits freely,
and you've built the easiest place on earth to park money.
Then there's the port.
Jebel Ali is the busiest in the Middle East,
moving cargo between Asia, Europe, and Africa.
Emirates and Dubai International Airport turn the city
into the world's connecting hub.
80% of the planet is under eight hours away.
Real estate did the rest.
The Burj Khalifa, Palm Jumeirah, entire artificial islands
built to attract the ultra-rich, then sold to them,
then taxed through fees, not income.
Oil built the roads.
Everything after that is what actually pays the bills.